it's important not to forget to report
on proven lies from this administration
even when the story has left the
headlines and case in point we now have
a Declassified internal White House memo
about that assassination of the Iranian
codes leader Kasim Soleimani which but
the memo now confirms that the imminent
threat posed by soleimani was not
actually part of the justification that
the White House internally was
discussing for his assassination
something we suspected at the time he
was not a threat imminently to the
United States or US interests and
initially they changed the
justifications but initially that was
the primary justification that the White
House gave now remember that the
explanations shifted first it was
Soleimani was an imminent threat he was
planning to do all sorts of violence
attack US embassies all sorts of stuff
when it started to become very clear
that that wasn't true they shifted to
well this is because of the things that
soleimani did in the past and
hilariously at one point Trump and his
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo we're not
even on the same page
Trump was repeating that it was because
of the imminent threat while Pompeo had
already shifted to saying it's because
of what he did in the past
then Trump ended up tweeting well it
doesn't even really matter why I did it
saying quote the fake news media and
their Democrat partners are working hard
to determine whether or not the future
attack by terrorists Soleimani was
imminent or not and was my team in
agreement the answer to both is a strong
yes but it doesn't really matter because
of his horrible past will we now have
the memo from the White House just to
kind of close this story out an imminent
threat is nowhere in there it's another
bogus dishonest talking point debunked
ultimately by their own documents the
only thing the memo says is that this
was a response to escalating attacks in
Prior months by Iran and Iran backed
militias the attack was meant to serve
as a sort of scare off deterrent to
future attacks and it simply then goes
into the legal justification for a why
Donald Trump was legally enabled and
able to do this
attack there was nothing there about
imminent threat there's nothing there
about the imminence claim that they
claim existed now I know it's been weeks
people have already forgotten about this
but it's important to document the lies
and we now have another one confirmed
and in a sense we already had it
confirmed Mike Pompeo very quickly
shifted from imminent threat to
repercussions for past actions reminder
of one of Pohnpei o's being slippery on
this at the time we needed a strike to
make sure that this imminent attack that
he was working actively was disrupted a
specific target overseas I'm not gonna
say anything more about the nature of
the attack but know that this was not
just in Iraq it was throughout the
region I was using these proxy forces
that he has manipulated for so long to
bring so much destruction to the Shias
and Sunnis the Muslims throughout the
region the man who inflicted enormous
arm not only on American lives but
created terribly destructive activities
supporting Lebanese Hezbollah Hamas the
Palestinian Lama jihad all of the bad
actors in the middle of my Qasem
Soleimani was at the center of all of it
was there any imminent threat to the US
homeland these were threats that were
located in the region right I mean I
guess maybe some threat in that region
not to the US and anyway it was
punishment for bad things he previously
did as they later went on to say and
Trump insisting he can do it either way
no matter what then Pompeo went on Fox
News and said well probably there was
some threat we just didn't know when or
where it would ultimately manifest and
then it went back to well no no it was
actually punishment for Kasim Soleimani
'he's past bad deeds it was a completely
incoherent shifting rationale from the
start we knew they were lying
and now the Declassified White House
memo confirms this not that anybody on
Trump's side is going to care but
important to do the work and to keep up
with debunking these lies and there are
many of them and they come fast and
furious do you feel like you just don't
have enough time to become as
intellectually well-rounded as you would
like to be that they're just not enough
hours in your week three
you to read all of the books that you
want to read one of our sponsors is
called blinka stand it's an app that
lets you consume an entire non-fiction
book in 15 minutes it's only about eight
bucks a month but you can try it for
free for a week and get 25% off a
subscription
when you go to blankest comm slash
Pakman what blinka studs is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and condense them into either text or
audio that you can read or listen to in
just 15 minutes and what you get is all
of the most important ideas and
information from the book imagine being
able to listen to an entire nonfiction
book in the amount of time it takes you
to drive or walk home from work I just
finished listening to catch and kill by
Ronan Farrow super interesting book
probably already familiar to some in my
audience and a really interesting take
at how Harvey Weinstein and his alleged
transgressions were brought to light
excellent investigative piece Blinky's
has totally transformed how I consume
information I love it of course I read a
book in its entirety when I can but
there are simply just so many books that
I want to read and would not have the
time for if it weren't for blankets they
have books on politics economics
philosophy science you name it you can
try it out yourself totally free for a
week and get 25% off if you decide to
subscribe just by going to blink is comm
slash Pakman I've put the link right
underneath this video like the rest of
us I bet you're going into 2020 thinking
about what you didn't get around to in
2019 and your goals for the new year if
you want to work towards being your best
self in 2020 understand more about the
world around you and make sure that your
time is well spent then blink astiz for
you